and having these setbacks where I can't
even run a mile but I'm thinking about
running
135 I can't run one mile and what if I
can win it it's a mental standard you
must meet in life
motivation has an expiration
date and when motivation dies discipline
must take it Place pick something rather
than nothing or pick something rather
than all things and then set yourself to
master that you need to have a primary
discipline it's absolutely necessary to
succeed in life now once you have a
primary discipline then you can Branch
out and and become a multiplicity in
your disciplined approach and then
you're absolutely bloody Unstoppable but
you really need that initial
disciplinary
routine